hello everyone welcome back to the
channel we got another south by
southwest 2022 interview for you right
now i am so thrilled to welcome some of
the team behind the documentary split at
the root to the channel we have
executive producer lana puria and also
producer marty knoxen hello
congratulations i am
very eager to talk about your film right
now
for either of you whoever wants to can
jump in on this with the festival
premiere our audience likely will not
know much about your movie just yet so
would anyone mind giving a brief
synopsis of split at the root
right
happy happy to jump in um
it is the story of
um
a
time in uh our country when
um the immigration policy
was
particularly cruel
um and families were being separated
from their kids uh at the border um
which still happens but this was a
particularly heinous time because kids
were not records weren't kept you know
families were divided um
and you know seeking asylum was uh
nearly impossible so
um
i heard about an organization that was
really grassroots
that was providing support for in
particular families and women who were
coming across who couldn't find their
children or didn't know where they were
or did know where they were and couldn't
reunite with them and
it was such a powerful story of
you know that so um
dramatically displayed the human cost
and then
ways in which
ordinary people in most cases women
could actually be impactful so
it was really a story of women on both
sides of our border it is a story of
women on both sides of our border
being badasses basically
so marty i hear you were pretty
instrumental in putting this whole thing
together from the very beginning so can
you kind of give us a sense of where it
all started and you know what what
inspired you like day of when you woke
up and said i have to tell this story
what was that thing that kind of got the
ball rolling um
i it it was fourth of july weekend i um
was inspired to do a matching fund
fundraiser uh on twitter i committed a
certain amount of money and joined with
um another woman and we basically just
went out to our our audience and um we
raised a fair amount of money and
at a certain point
um with a with a bot with the
organization that was bonding people out
but at a certain point i got a text from
a friend who lived in new york and she
said
if you have more money or you want to do
this again you should know about this
organization ift
immigrant families together and she
explained to me that this was this group
of
mostly moms in new york city who were
going the distance they were bonding
people out but they weren't leaving it
at that they were
helping to arrange transport for people
who couldn't fly because of their you
know their immigration status you know
they were doing caravans across the
country they were and my friend said you
know i'm sitting in an immigration
office right now with my daughter who
was a baby waiting for a bond
and i was like
this is incredible
um you know we all felt so powerless at
that moment and this was so tangible it
was really person to person
and then i got introduced to julie and
francisco and all these incredible
people involved and i have a friend who
is the director of this movie um linda
goldstein knowlton and i i said to ift
i'm gonna send you a donation i'm also
sending you a documentary filmmaker
because my story sense went this is this
is something people need to know about
and so
um you know we got linda to go out there
and we literally just started filming as
soon as we heard about the project and
so i think we thought it would be
you know a year or two we were literally
trying to get it out for the 2020
election
um
and um
2020 yes
it's all a blur now yeah
and that was it and that wasn't um
feasible but in a way that really
served us because the story that's gone
beyond that
period and also um now through a change
of administration it it's all the more
powerful for that all right lana now for
your involvement here what is your very
first reaction when marty comes your way
with this opportunity is it a no-brainer
right from the start given the
importance of the subject matter or does
the fact that it's your first producing
credit you know create any hesitation or
make you think i don't know if i could
do this well i feel like it's a
combination of the two you know being a
latin woman as well and being the
daughter of an immigrant of uh you know
the great granddaughter of immigrants
um
it's it's really an interesting sort of
like seeing this documentary had me
think about
how the immigration crisis has affected
my family dramatically and in turn has
affected me
being the offspring of all of them you
know so it's
it was um
i remember learning about the zero
tolerance policy uh i think it
i think it was entitled that in 2018
and we really as a country started
seeing bits of it you know on the news
in 2019 and
i was just completely horrified i am not
a supporter of the trump administration
already to begin with so it seeing that
this was happening in our very own
country was nauseating
and i
you know i i am a mother to so many i
don't have children of my own but i
love children i've raised children
and the fact that
any government can tear children away
from their families is just
ungodly
and i felt like
i had an opportunity to be of service um
jumping on board being part of this team
using my platform to raise awareness
you know
sharing this documentary with our youth
you know like i said earlier they're our
future we had a little tiny conversation
before you hopped on marty and
and um you know it is imperative that
they know what's going on in this
country and and and hopefully it will
inspire them to do something you know um
so
yes it's my first executive producer
credit and i've never you know i i've
been in scripted television and film for
so long so this is very new for me
um i am inspired and moved by all these
women including marty it's just everyone
involved
um
the courage to witness and and jenny and
and yenni
uh um and um
some people say jenny some people say
yeni but it's a it's a latin name so
it's uh my cousin's name is jesenya and
it's with a y and and jenny is the same
with the y and to see these women rosie
and jenny just
you know fighting for their lives their
families and
and the courage
you know that these women have is just
so inspiring
um so i'm i'm very honored to be a part
of this um and and i'm very excited to
see what you know where we go with it
i did have another question of the
producing of it all for you because when
i did look it up i was surprised to see
that this was your first producer credit
and it was just making me wonder have
you ever had the opportunity whether
it's once upon a time or anything you've
worked on before to to kind of jump into
that field but maybe it wasn't right but
now is the right time and then if that
was the case did this kind of you know
create that itch that you need to keep
scratching and keep producing from here
on out
well thank you for asking that i'm i've
actually been in development for the
past four years on several projects um a
couple of them haven't quite taken off
um but we have one right now that we're
keeping our fingers crossed for and i
have another one that i'm working on and
i've been an executive producer on those
and also starring in one of them so um
it you know nowadays you can't just be
an actor okay you have to be a director
you have to be a producer and stepping
out of once upon a time which was a
total like bubble up in canada
for seven years i stepped back into the
industry going uh what's going on now
you know and i and i realized like how
expansive television television has
become and you know all these women whom
i admire greatly one of them is my
dearest friend eva longoria you know
rosario dawson like seeing what these
women latin women are doing in the
industry has always been an inspiration
so yes i am i'm i'm very excited about
my new producing career
i love here and i told you before i love
seeing someone with a big platform
taking on those kinds of roles on other
projects because the truth of the matter
is some folks out there won't see these
films otherwise so it's it's a big deal
that you're committing to that and i
can't applaud it enough
um
let's talk a little bit about the
structure of the film i was i was
curious marty was this and in particular
i guess focusing on rosie and yeti's
experiences was that always going to be
the structure for the movie or did you
ever play around with other avenues to
explore
i mean in truth this was one of those um
projects where it started just super
scrappy i mean we were just like film
and see although you know wrote um
jenny's story
and rosie's story were both sort of in
progress
and what's great about you know what's
great about it is that there are um
there was footage
um before we jumped in um you know
particularly with yenni um jenny now you
got me
sorry marty
thank you
um jenny and so um
and i think that one of the issues was
like not wanting to center
um
you know ma you know the the mom so much
in ift um as
as the women who were coming over the
border and what had affected them and
their stories
you know sort of naturally came to the
forefront um but like a lot of
documentaries you sort of start with one
idea um and then it it blossoms into
something you know
just more specific or and again we
didn't think that we'd be filming for so
long
we started this in 2018 we really didn't
think that we'd be
um you know completing it now um but
it's also been so helpful to have people
like lana and um rosario and all these
incredible people who've supported us
because like a lot of documentaries
we've sort of been scraping by
um you know and the an interesting thing
for me is that you know with other
things i've been involved with in terms
of um
you know organizations that that are
helpers
you know when the media focus goes away
from that um when it's not the top story
on the news it's sometimes really hard
to remind people that this is a
situation that is ongoing and could very
well happen again
um and and could very well happen again
with the same kind of cruelty um so i
think one of the reasons why we're sort
of grateful that the movie took longer
um is that you really are able to follow
these women's stories and and one of the
things about ift that's been so
inspiring is they don't it's not like a
that we do just this part and then we
jump out
it's like we are offering support um to
these families through the whole process
and through you know their asylum
decisions through the support people
need when they first come here you know
they can't work um until they are
granted asylum there's all these things
that um and in the at the end of the
movie you see that rosie is still hoping
to get her green card in order to bring
her daughters you know she hasn't seen
her daughters in person since she
left
her country so
you know i think that
that's a long answer to you you kind of
never know but in this case you know
the access to these women and and how
powerfully they were able to tell their
stories just sort of made the decision
for us
i also had a
big old compound question i guess that's
going to get very complicated about your
history working with documentaries
correct me if i'm wrong but this is only
the second documentary feature you
worked on so
why the weight between code black and
this and is there anything you learn
working on code black that you found
coming in handy on split at the root
well i also have to give ample credit to
you know to linda and to maria i mean
this was something they really took on
and um and the same was true of code
black it was much more about you know
linda worked on that as well and it was
much more about me connecting the right
people
um and you know i'm not a documentary
filmmaker um i'm a you know narrative
has you know um drama and narrative
fiction have been my bread and butter um
weirdly though my dad was a documentary
filmmaker he worked with national
geographic for
all of my life
and um and i think that i i i know that
you can apply the same sort of story
sense that i have to a situation or a
thing that feels really compelling and
and what's interesting is in both cases
it's just sort of i wasn't looking these
things were presented to me like
you know i just with code black they
were already filming but they had no
idea what to do with the footage and i
literally was at a kid's birthday party
and one of the moms that i knew told me
that her brother had was filming inside
county hospital
and could i talk to him and
then with this it was just finding out
about the the work everybody was doing
by chance
and going okay that's a story that needs
to be told especially right now so um
yeah it's not my bread and butter but i
know a lot of really amazing people who
do it and when i have the opportunity or
i feel like there's something that just
you know is irresistible i i now have
this
amazing um you know all these amazing
relationships and i can bring people
together and help them do the work that
they need to do
all right i got a big question to wrap
up for both of you here and you kind of
touched on this a little but just to
hammer it home a little harder right now
what would you say to someone out there
who says you know i've seen enough of
this on the news i get i get it i don't
need more of this this story and this
situation in my life why is this
documentary essential viewing that gives
them insight that they can't get
anywhere else in any other format well i
think that i mean
uh you know how can we not take a look
at what's happening in our very own
country you know just it's a human
crisis
like it's not just like oh it's
immigration it's really about it's
humanity how are we choosing to treat
people
you know and and that is everyone's
responsibility
so you can't just sit back idle and do
nothing about it
you have to take action on some level
because it's
where unified
be like you know
unified countries like you know it feels
so divided but like you know if if we're
going to call ourselves the united
states and the land of the free then we
actively as residents
we need to
do something to help everyone feel safe
on some level you know and um
i really truly believe when i first saw
this you know a rough rough cut of the
documentary
i immediately wanted to get in my car
and drive to the south of the border and
be like what the hell is going on and
protest and try to help and be of
service
so i i really am
hoping that the people who watch this
film
are also inspired to do something about
it and that that is the point of really
you know shining a light on these
stories and putting them out there for
the world to see
yeah and and to me
everything you said
um and also like
i think people believe they know the
story
but when you put human um
faces and experiences to that story
um
it it
you know whether you take action or not
i hope that you look at women like jenny
and rosie and you're like they should be
in this country
you know they are the kind of citizens
that we have
we have
you know built this country
with and together with and um they are
incredibly important to the to the
future of our country and the fact that
we treat asylum seekers like criminals
when
i hope i'm getting this right i didn't
know that i'm trying to cross the border
for asylum is a misdemeanor
um it's and they're treated like
you know um drug cartel members i mean
it's it's unbelievable so
if only to have more compassion for
people you don't necessarily you think
you understand but you don't
and also to see where these people come
from and the the
the fact that they in many cases are
making life and death decisions for
themselves and their children
again i think sometimes we we you know
all of us sort of think we understand
but we don't um so for me it's always
about empathy it's the same thing i i
focus on in my work like i think empathy
creates action or it should
um you know and in in some cases the
action is just
kindness and i this is reductive but i
was so moved by the kindness of of all
the people involved in this and the
humanness um so even a reminder just to
not make assumptions about people to not
look at their stories and think you know
so
and and again like it's just a very
moving story and it's hopeful
um that's the part that was so difficult
i think and why i wanted to get involved
because you feel so powerless
and you feel like there's nobody
that will do the right thing um and then
you watch this movie and you're like i'm
you know if only i send money to ift
or you know or i support organizations
that i i'll say this one last thing
people need to do their homework about
where they send their money
um and people need to really understand
the impact of these organizations um you
know
no disrespect to the organization that i
helped raise money for but they they
basically provide the bond and what we
learned in our movie is that it takes so
much more than that um to actually help
these people stay here reunite their
families um and and so again you know
it's just looking at things through a
more um focused lens and um and i think
the movie's so successful at that i also
think it's yeah it is hopeful and it's
also really emotional it made me it made
me believe in people again
the hopeful nature of it was very
inspiring to answer my own last question
it's it's like that's that's why i i
think i need a documentary like this in
addition to the information that i get
via news is because often news lacks
that hope or
lacks that uh the ability to point you
in the direction to actually take action
on your own whereas this movie provides
the hope to inspire you to do it and
even gives you the proper information in
order to make those smart decisions when
you want to support a cause
i must let you go
thank you for your time today
congratulations on the film i am very
eager to see it get out there even
further beyond south by southwest thank
you all right thank you so much